el término garantía
garantía
se usa mucho en la industria
inmobiliaria aunque también en las
transacciones financieras en general
pero la venta y compra de bienes raíces
es en donde lo encontramos más
comúnmente e incluso en el contexto de
bienes raíces ese término tiende a ser
usado de dos formas diferentes lo que lo
hace un poco más confuso una forma en la
que se usa el término de garantía es en
el momento que se hace la compra de la
casa lo que sucede es que se hace una
oferta para comprar esta casa
el vendedor acepta esa oferta y en ese
momento se da la apertura de una cuenta
de garantía y esto es una cuenta que va
a estar en custodia de un tercero
confiable así que esta es la cuenta de
garantía que va estar administrada por
una tercera persona
tercera persona de confianza tanto para
el comprador como para el vendedor
y lo que sucede es que el comprador va a
poner todas sus obligaciones dentro de
esta cuenta como por ejemplo el depósito
que acompaña el contrato de oferta
también podría ser el resto del pago de
enganche esto es el enganche
y también va a ingresar el dinero que
recibe por financiamiento para completar
el pago de esta casa aquí va lo de el
financiamiento que recibió del banco
financiamiento
financiamiento y lo mismo va a ser el
vendedor
el vendedor va a permitir que se
inspeccione su casa e imaginemos que la
casa aprueba la inspección entonces se
aprueba
la inspección
imaginemos también que la compañía que
investiga los títulos y escrituras hizo
su investigación de los títulos de esta
casa y todo está en orden
así que aquí tenemos un título
limpio sin ningún tipo de problemas y al
final llegando a la fecha de cierre que
de hecho esa fecha límite o esa fecha de
cierre va a ser la fecha en la que se va
a cerrar esta cuenta de garantía así que
en la fecha de cierre en el cierre está
tercera persona de confianza dice bueno
todos los involucrados cumplieron con
sus obligaciones así que ahora le voy a
dar al vendedor su dinero y le daré al
comprador el título de propiedad
el título
de propiedad
o la escritura
y en otro vídeo analizamos todo esto con
más detalle pero este es solo una forma
de tener garantía donde hay una tercera
persona de confianza que va a resguardar
las obligaciones de los demás
involucrados y en la fecha de cierre va
a darle a cada quien lo que le
corresponde siempre y cuando todos hayan
cumplido sus obligaciones otra forma en
la que usamos el término garantía de los
bienes raíces también involucra tener a
una tercera persona de confianza por eso
es que este término significa garantía
vamos a tener a alguien en quien podemos
confiar que nos va a garantizar que las
cosas se realicen de la manera en que
deben de realizarse por todos los
involucrados y de esta manera facilitar
las transacciones el otro lugar en donde
encontramos este término es cuando se
contrata una hipoteca típicamente cuando
hablamos de pagos de hipotecas nuestro
pago mensual de la hipoteca es
digamos para mantenerlo simple que es de
mil dólares
este es el pago de mi hipoteca que vale
y si ese fuera nuestro primer pago de la
hipoteca una parte de éste va a ir a los
intereses del préstamo cuando comenzamos
la mayor parte del pago va a ir a los
intereses
intereses y la otra parte va a ir a
pagar el préstamo principal o el capital
y ya hemos visto el detalle de esto en
otros vídeos el siguiente pago de la
hipoteca el siguiente mes lo que voy a
pagar esos mil dólares que voy a pagar
si es que tenemos una hipoteca de tasa
fija vamos a pagar un poquito más hacia
la tasa principal y un poquito menos a
los intereses pero cuando se está
escribiendo el cheque para el banco
podemos darnos cuenta que estamos
pagando un poco más de estos mil dólares
y nos preguntamos bueno pero porque
estamos pagando más de mil dólares pues
si llamamos al banco y le preguntamos al
respecto nos van a decir que sí bueno
nosotros no podemos pagar esta hipoteca
y el banco se quedará con la casa
quieren asegurarse de que la casa esté
apropiadamente asegurada y quieren
asegurarse también de que se han pagado
los impuestos que le corresponden a esta
casa
porque les interesa que esté asegurada
la casa pues porque si esta casa no
estuviera asegurada y ocurre algún
desastre natural cayera un huracán en
esta área y destrozar a esta propiedad o
un tornado y la destruyera por completo
pues podrían pensar que el dueño
abandoné la hipoteca ya que pues la
propiedad deja de existir y con lo que
se quedaría el banco pues es con una
casa destruida así que por eso les
interesa que la casa esté asegurada y
también les interesa que vaya al
corriente en el pago de impuestos porque
si se falla en el pago de los impuestos
y el dueño se va abandona esta casa el
banco tendrá que pagar todas esas multas
por los impuestos no pagados así que lo
que puede hacer el banco es decir que y
aquí voy a modificar un poco los números
para que nos salgan bien las cuentas vas
a tener que pagar mil doscientos dólares
anuales por seguro
y también vas a tener que pagar 1200
dólares anuales en impuestos
esto nos va a dar un total de
2.400 dólares anuales y esto es de
seguro e impuestos a veces se abrevia
como y más s impuestos más seguros
y como queremos asegurarnos de que esto
lo pagues el banco dice bueno cada mes
vas a pagar una doceava parte de esto
así que cada mes se van a pagar 200
dólares
además del pago de la hipoteca para
cubrir esto
y esto va a ir a una cuenta en garantía
o en custodia así que voy a pagar además
200 dólares cada mes y estos van a ir a
una cuenta de garantía o de custodia
dónde va lo que nos interesa tener de
impuestos y seguro
una cuenta en garantía
y la persona que administra esta cuenta
en garantía cada vez que reciban una
cuenta por impuestos o seguro ellos lo
pagarán del dinero que se encuentra en
esta cuenta nuevamente esta es una
cuenta que es administrada por una
tercera persona de confianza cuyo
propósito es administrar el dinero que
se deposite acá para pagar impuestos y
seguros el comprador quiere asegurarse
de que este dinero no vaya al banco para
que el banco no se lo vaya a gastar en
otra cosa y además el banco también le
interesa que este dinero se reciba y se
administre porque también le conviene
que se pague el seguro y los impuestos
de esta propiedad y estas son las dos
formas principales en las que trabajamos
con el término garantía en los bienes
raíces
vamos representan la misma idea de poner
dinero en una cuenta que va a ser usada
con un propósito específico pero es
usada en dos contextos diferentes aquí
en estos casos aquí la tenemos para
facilitar la transacción de una compra
de una casa y este ejemplo muestra el
uso de una garantía para asegurarnos que
se pagan ciertos servicios